welcome to the cooking phase tasks  series in this video we'll take a look  at the text-to-speech or dds task  now this question about audio tasks  would be complete without talking about  tds  in text-to-speech natural sounding  speech is generated by a model keeping a  text input  libraries such as espn.net and  tensorflow.dts allows you to easily load  any of the over 100 pre-trained models  by the community  and this can even be expanded to  multiple speakers and multiple languages  there are metrics such as log f0 that  allow us to evaluate the models by  reflecting content similarities but it's  very challenging to determine the  perceptual quality so usually there are  humans in the loop that perform  qualitative evaluation  you can try it out right now in a space  demo or by using the hosted widgets in  each of the model repositories  for more information about dts check out  the task pages  you